est ce qu'on a déjà envoyé un nude sur
type doc / tik tok non mais sur
instagram juifs j'ai régulièrement des
jeunes femmes qui m'envoient des
messages dans se voir comment ça va tu
disponibles ok bah non en fait je n'ai
jamais demandé c'est quoi l'amour ligne
routine de jésus ouailles en assure tik
tok sont déjà au taquet à nous parler du
car est maintenu aujourd'hui l'église
nous avons fêté l'épiphanie
[Musique]
tourné la vidéo qui a le plus 2 et sur
tictoc ça c'est incroyable la vidéo qui
a le plus buzzé cette vidéo que j'ai
fait vite fait bien fait pour répondre à
la question comment sont payés les
prêtres ça ne paraissait complètement
superflu mais cette vidéo a dû faire 400
me de vue je crois les prêtresses ont
payé par les dons des fidèles qui donne
à l'église et l'église nous reverse
quelque chose donc on a on a ce qu'il
faut pour vivre on n'est pas dans la
misère
tu es déjà tombés amoureux oui mais
ensuite j'ai fait le choix de répondre à
l'appel du christ qui m'appelait au
célibat est aujourd'hui ma vie elle est
donnée au christ j'ai pas choisi le
célibat pour devenir un vieux garçon
j'ai choisi le célibat pour un projet
denis pour un idéal de vie pour être
donnée à aux hommes et aux femmes que je
rencontre c'est parce que moi si tu as
une relation sexuelle en tant que prêtre
il se passe que je dois être honnête
avec avec l'église
je dois d'abord demandé pardon aux
seniors parce que j'ai pas été fidèle à
l'engagement que j'ai pris et puis je
dois librement faire la démarche d'aller
voir mon évêque et de lui en parler de
lui expliquer ce qui s'est passé et de
me donner les moyens de mettre un terme
à cette relation
oui c'est ça exactement
est ce que tu fais du sport oui j'essaye
d'aller courir une ou deux fois par
semaine on dit qu'on évite les activités
qui nous mettent en danger qu'ils sont
trop dangereux de se balancer un peu
dans les sports de combat oui ce
pourrait être le sport de combat les
sports extrêmes voilà tu regardes date
fixe j'ai piqué les codes à un copain
mais je m'en suis servi deux fois c'est
quoi la dernière série j'ai regardé j'en
ai regardé aucune voix est ce que tu as
des amis non croyants ouais j'en ai pas
mal
enfin surtout mes amis du du lycée et
puis des gens que je rencontre à droite
à gauche et ça donne lieu à des
discussions enflammées enflammé je
dirais pas mais en tout cas des
discussions et régulièrement il ya des
sujets sur lesquels sur lesquels on
débat comme quoi par exemple
après un plein plein de questions mais
des questions de foi cette chose sont
fondamentales est ce que dieu puisse
devenir sommes à un moment donné comme
nous le croyons avec jésus-christ est ce
que dieu peut être père fils et
saint-esprit mais un seul dieu comment 3
égales a déjà consommé de l'alcool
bien sûr au moins tous les jours à la
messe pour le le vin de messe mais je
suis pas le dernier à prendre l'apéro
avec des amis et c'est pas interdit de
boire de l'alcool quand on est chrétien
et les mêmes déboires de trois verres
mais toute la question de raison et de
modération et pour la drogue la drogue
alors il ya d'abord une question légale
et puis la deuxième question c'est de de
rester en fait tous et la drogue
l'alcool nous font perdre nos moyens et
donc perdre notre volonté et notre
liberté à se tient là c'est qu'on a une
volonté
donc tout ce qui vient nous faire perdre
notre volonté finalement s'oppose à
notre liberté et dieu nous a créés pour
la liberté
pourquoi tu es devenu prêtre parce que
j'ai fait l'expérience quand j'avais 16
ans que notre vie ne se limitait pas à
ce qu'il y avait sur la terre mais qui
avait un dieu et que ce dieu nous a mais
d'un amour fou et c'était amour fou je
l'ait expérimentée au plus profond de
moi même et donc j'ai dit oh seigneur si
tu m'aimes comme ça moi je suis prêt de
suivre et à faire ce que tu veux
il m'a fallu trois ans pour entendre
qu'il m'appelait à devenir prêtre lui
dans la vie d'un prêtre plus durs dans
la vie d'un prêtre
je crois que c'est de rencontrer des
gens qui ne comprennent pas la beauté du
message du christ voilà et qui pensent
que c'est négligeable
je me pose parfois des questions je me
dis dès fois quel est le sens de ce que
je vis mais des regrets
aucun et si je devais demain me
réengager je me réengage ray